welcome to spoiler Carter whoo spoiler
rough still not get take that off I
could really still like that take that
off no I'm in character okay we're gonna
find out like throughout the whole thing
like your audio can't be hurt or
something like that underwater Thank You
Debby on sister um okay all the email
would be going to you though yes a
defense assistant so um yeah there are
like a fuck time oh yeah where do we
start with movies just one giant spoiler
yeah so um alright so the bad guy is han
solo son um I thought he was amazing
though uh I thought he was very good I
like a funny baby's name okay the
animators well I was looking at him like
you know what I can almost see Harrison
Ford I could totally see it and it's
rough voice too and when he takes the
mask off it's not like oh it's like he's
kind of a pretty boy but it's like no
but that seems right that seems right
like what do you know is he's a pretty
boy but like just a very evil pretty boy
which is kind of it's creepier in its
own way he's not be hardened disfigured
no I I thought was a very good choice um
the he sells it with his president
although I think of it the given moments
of comedy too
well yeah but the storms rivers like
turning around as it goes nuts the
comedy this is very very good to make
you forget to mention uh did you get a
look at the end even though I know
that's the IDSA is going back and forth
and stuff like that but he still seemed
to be in control and when he's you know
when he was losing use kind of a shaky
voices though which was great but then
at the end he's a traitor
traitors I will kill you I look it's
like give you a little Anakin there from
like Revenge of the Sith a little bit I
think you're I think you're missing
something here which is did you notice
after Han fell the look on the guy's
face well I can't kylo Ren says there
was this sigh of relief like I think the
concept is now it's allowed him to go
fully dark like he's always been holding
back and I was like ah and then the
hatred can it just comes in and starts
well that brings us to spoil a number
two solo dies which the minister oh it's
so long solo
uh the minute they said I think we were
talking about even before we knew oh no
I said I'm like think because it's no
secret that Harrison Ford wanted to die
in the original trilogy and I feel I
feel like there was a story that
Lawrence Kasdan wanted to do it and
Lucas overruled him and I've been saying
along with I've got a friend and she's
been saying the same thing and I think
you've been hinting at it too that you
just know Caston and Ford are just
waiting for it just waiting to do it now
that they finally have the chance my
only thing is I thought they were gonna
hold off on that till I was gonna be
movie - but yeah as soon as it's
revealed that's Han Solo's son I'm like
dead like so gone like we're originals
like okay it's either gonna be either
you know cuz they're not showing Luke
it's either gonna be solo or Luke that
dies one of them has it wasn't it wasn't
there just cuz I was like well I don't
know where we're going with this yeah
maybe they're gonna flesh out their
backstory more and then kill it like so
I still don't maybe movie - it was first
off when when Leia is like I'm gonna
miss you and hug I'm like alright this
I'm like this is seeing seemed pretty
obvious but it was when Han just sees
kylo Ren walk by and he gets his like
I'm like gone
yeah like okay that's where this go and
the second he starts walking on the
platform out of Empire Strikes Back I'm
like oh well on top of that I mean he
has so much free time I think a lot of
people think like oh he's gonna have
like a cameo so he's in this movie a lot
and they don't not really oh this book
that's not a complaint at all oh my god
very I thought really we were just gonna
get teased with more like a kind of
cameo from him and I'm like no he's a
frickin maker but I mean just - just
tell me if any of this sounds familiar
so a droid has these plans for this
resistance of rebellion whatever you
want to call it get sent to a desert
planet comes across this person who
lives on the desert planet and has the
force and Trey has to outrun this Empire
who is also looking for the Droid comes
across this green pretty planet that
also happens ahead lay up looking at a
green screen guess what they're making
another giant boat which is a planet
which is really cool it has like an
atmosphere every day that's amazing but
another giant ball still and guess what
the giant ball destroys planet it
destroys a few more planets great but it
still destroys planets guess what
they're going after at the end they're
gonna go after the planet that has the
rebels at home sorry the resistance on
it with Leia looking at this green
screen they even fucking c-3po is there
and guess how they have to stop it some
shits have to go up there fly around go
into the middle of it and shoot it oh
and guess what the mentor the mentor -
ready there there they really getting a
lot of stuff like that key dies yeah
that's my lightsaber because any of that
any of that sound familiar
yeah this wasn't listening okay that's
huh I was just really no one else out
there hey this is like you know this
sounds a little too familiar just a
little too familiar as I said it's been
going on since the prequels I don't know
that maybe we can like I said maybe
because first even the first fucking
trilogy didn't when Luke slices up
Vader's hand and sees he's got a robot
hand as well oh no no you do better than
that going in destroying the Death Star
yes I can hi-yah that's like one of the
three times the fucking truck you know
and wipe you don't want to see I want to
see them try to destroy that thing
it fails and then they just start like
five more planets it's like shit what
are we gonna do I don't know we'll find
out in the next movie I guess we lost
today or something hey we've been really
good right um okay
what is other thing destroy whether you
see it blow up like remember like you
were talking about how so well done in
the first film the deaths are being
blown up was it don't feel anything when
that won't losing before shut up I will
give you this of all the repeats just
doing another Death Star type of weapon
is the one that I was kind of like
really fucking really I'm like it looks
kind of cool in this matter but I mean
they're even making fun of it in the
movie because there's always like some
way to blow
oh yeah well not only that but even
where he's like alright so it's just
really bigger than the other one away
yeah no he's really so young kind of
what I know so that did bother me and
you do bring up a good point it would be
cool thing I actually thought that's
where they were going with it that they
were that the resistance or whatever was
gonna lose and that this thing was gonna
be on the loose of the second film and
she was gonna have to train to be a Jedi
oh yeah she is like got force powers ray
um that's another spoiler well I don't
think that it's not really a spoiler
didn't everybody can know that I think I
don't think so there was some guests
they were like well friends gonna be the
Jedi cuz you've got the one favor and
I'm like mouth doesn't even say like you
know my father has it I have it my
sister has it and you have it too and
you see him like handy no idea which is
not in the moment but that's what I said
and I fucking call because I thought
whatever there were they're like no
stupid no it was so clear that she was
like that's what I thought but there are
these arguments like wrong no feel like
grants alight serger is like shit like
you I'm gonna call it now Luke's
daughter
uh that's my get what I figured oh no no
I'm thinking it's a babble of a cousin
no no yet no it's either Luke's daughter
or my thought possibly was um this was
like it can't be no it can't be a do cuz
as much as their ring ringing this damn
thing I cannot imagine them doing a
brother-sister thing again no I'm not
fucking imagine it I would almost get up
and walk if they did that yeah I guess
it won't be cut but there's quite
obviously a connection there yeah um
probably family because everybody's
related in a galaxy far far away you
know four galaxies I mean fucking
galaxies everybody seems to be connected
somehow just a lot inbreeding there's
nothing how the force work yeah I guess
Luke and Leia raised a lobby bring um
but maybe that's what spawned all this
is too much inbreeding in that family
let's say you know every other ones up
yeah um and uh but yeah so but but
here's the thing I the the battle
between her and him with the lightsabers
and mammals I fucking ate that shit up
see I am sorry like your sin they're
like mmm mmm mmm I like I like sit there
like peanut M&Ms in hand just like I'm
wrong I'm through the Stormtrooper how
it was quite difficult um yeah I loved
that and it was the first time in a
while room like okay this feels mythic
again like we're going back to something
that I did feel was ancient or I did
definitely which I really like did
definitely feel the mythos ISM in this
especially the last shot in this I mean
is like right out of the last shot was
great with with the reveal of Luke and
her climbing up the steps of his film in
some island and sky yeah and and I love
the scene where the after they fight and
she gets the better of him the canyon
splits apart I'm just like gorgeous
metaphor brilliant I mean again that I
think driving it all the more they're
gonna be related oh I got if they
weren't related I'm calling it I'm
saying cousin that that's probably the
most logical I think it could be
possible to brother and sister but I'll
say cousin David I'm sorry that would
piss me a lot you think that'd be too
much repeat command I'm not that right
down to their stomach you know even the
bad guy is related to Luke Skywalker
even at that uh um but yeah it's such a
killjoy I know I bet it's but it was
done for the most part well I mean
that's the thing it's like that the
comedies in the right places is still
kind of felt mythical and stuff like
that you know sound last I want even
anyway she scars his face which seems to
be some common theme which is whenever
you use the dark side you're gonna get
fucking scar yeah um you know it's just
one of those things where it's like yeah
when I got to that final bit I was I was
kind of saying myself odd she like this
this is the climax isn't it huh I see
yeah I I thought if apart from the
x-wing battle which I thought was which
for me was probably the only let
that the whole climax I love ate the
whole thing up from from above nice I
mean they started the attack you know
basically from when solo dies on through
the end I was completely with it apart
from the x-wing stuff and I was just
putting up with NSA on the exact
opposite like everything before the oh I
mean like okay we'll talk about that too
the bin in outer space whether on the
freighter and the little octopus yeah
that was a total pointless diversion
yeah I just got a I'm like those octopus
things look horrible
yeah it was not God it wasn't god awful
seemed like but it definitely was like
I'm like okay this may be the weakest
part of the movie yeah like it's an ass
to end them yeah yeah you got a solo
doing some more han solo ain't trying to
bargain in sandwiches I loved the first
third like I do think the best part of
the movie is that first bit setting up
ray and Finn's character the watching
the two of them and then after they take
off from the planet and from jakku um
yeah it's okay
you know it's good and I feel it's solid
I loved the cantina bit I loved her
flashback work reveals you know that
Luke's calling to her and women I love
the fact that she runs away from the
lightsabers like ah this shit yeah it
was great speech fun about running away
but yeah they got in and then is so yeah
I like that but I still felt like the
middle kind of just goes in and out and
about then they attack and right when
Han dies it was right about there like
the pacing be editing the directing I
feel like everything just suddenly
switched out like he was just waiting
for that moment that's so funny I was
like the exact opposite I thought as
soon as he dies we're you know we saw it
coming but it's like okay it's it's fine
to go this direction you know I mean
it's ill I say it felt right it felt
right to go this direction
um it's that like I said I you know
there you know she's not gonna die
there's nothing particularly
psychological going on there it's like
he has her against a cliff she's a the
force
and then she fights better whatever the
sort of fighting is not very interesting
to look at I mean especially after again
the one a few good things in the
prequels the like hey sorry the sword
fight isn't like three hours long no but
I mean getting longer better but again
there there wasn't like I don't know if
there's what he says you know you know
you could join me to join the dark side
if there was more of that that would
have been interesting that would have
been more engaging because that's what
the film's is well not this one mine I'm
saying if there was more of it of
Morcant or even a soliloquy no but like
in Return of the Jedi when he's like
trying to win Luke over and stuff like
that if he was doing that whether you've
been much more interested traitor I'll
kill your progress like it your realize
they're still in movie one I mean that
may be one of my one of the few things
you see everything else anyway that may
be one of strange things about this film
is in a weird way there's so much going
on that I'm surprised this was all one
movie because it pretty much did new
hope and Empire with Ben own Empire is
going to be Luke training her which is
gonna be the next movie which on the one
hand thing we didn't get from Empire
otherwise we've got we've got that same
scene with the long platform we've got
him taking them out there's like reveal
like he's our son like it's I just get
to him and script but I think that that
is the thing it's just like I'm like wow
we pretty much did most of the trilogy
in one movie and I'll kind of surprise
most of the stuff with the characters I
thought the strength was the the
environment with with mostly the the
landscapes and the practical effects and
the creativity stuff and the characters
I really think in a lot of respects the
the repeat of the story is a major
weakness and I think that really shows
in that climax because it's just uh not
interests you feel nothing when that
plant blows up you don't feel like wow
they did it that was a big thank God now
let you say again now that
I say again I already told you that the
planet thing was that we see you're
making them about the planet it was
about those two not about the planet
those two had one scene prior which was
a good scene and then they have that
slave you know that good scene was like
on the set of pieces of the movie that
like set everything up right then and
then they just Clank some sorts he says
one line that connects them at all and
then they just like well we're actually
just sleeping in another class arts
again best oh okay well I'll tell you
what we'll just put on the prequels and
you can sit there with your taxation and
Federation routes hey you're the one
that wanted to see that um but know that
I mean I think it's one we're just going
to disagree on cuz I felt yeah I mean
you're like novellas very Buddhist but
compromisable say ever but beliefs I
think it came back when she travels
which like it technically doesn't make
sense so I don't want everybody go with
her to find Luke Skywalker but um by
when she but I still like it again it's
like I let go cuz it was beautiful and
it was mythical when she goes season my
top of the mountain I mean classic
classic mythos and anything might say so
it was late just like tell Luke I said
hi yeah buddy like isn't funny you know
what this turns off the galaxy is trying
to find lenders and suspending disbelief
though because you need that moment of
the two alone yeah Leia just hang out in
the background hi lot I mean or not
really might and with yeah no but my
thought is that they'll probably stay
away i me honestly that he'll you know
he'll trainer or whatever I bet that'd
be my guess
Oh should we I forgot to I wish I
mentioned this in the other one uh we'll
do this play with corner I missed the
first paragraph of the scroll because
obviously this is opening night there's
a bunch of Star Wars fans you're like
the opening line
you know uh sir episode 7 uh the force
awakens is says Luke Skywalker has
vanished
and the guy behind us literally goes Oh
finished vanished what the fuck
oh finish not saw Luke's face on a milk
carton or something I don't know maybe
you have to be there but it was just all
those things it was so like so hard for
that's one of those things where it's
just like I don't think he likes that
plot twist and I'm like wow that's the
first fucking line in the paragraph
we're in big trouble if you don't like
this already maybe everything about the
way the Galaxy was laid out was in that
first paragraph that we missed mail
about the taxation but rather it's there
it's like there's an empire there's a
resistance but I don't get it I'm like
how does the resistance fit into this if
the Republic still there the other
confusing thing was I thought they
fucking blew up chorus and in the middle
of this they have planet they blew up I
thought that was coarsely like dampers
yeah it was on top of the seat of empire
but it looked like that I'm like did it
just fucking blow up Cory did I just see
them and then later I got some star
system Adama okay and that's kind of
what I mean like I feel like it needed
to be just somehow explained a little
better what's important what's not just
give us a better idea because idea cuz
yeah I thought really that I just kind
of like breeze through some core sample
you know they're like holy shit that the
first film the new hope works so well
because you you know the importance of
what's going on in that universe and and
the environment and stuff like that and
you also know what's important to the
maker the simple main characters this
one I feel you you get what's important
to the main characters you don't get
what's important why that and these work
fuck the stupid planet blowing up but I
knew it I knew I was important to those
two main characters I was completely
wrapped up in their story and the fight
and the struggle they had and her trying
to defend Finn and Finn defending her
and like that's where it worked if they
had maybe one more scene that seemed
ready she was getting tortured by you
know like it was amazing I thought you
didn't told you everything you needed to
know he had only like five lines of
dialogue no no and I I thought a lot was
done in that scene and again
was mostly not even the dialogue I like
the way they showed that she's actually
kind of stronger than him just kind of
naturally you know when she served with
Jackson back and that's all done
visually it's very well done I love like
one more bit of like a connection a
little bit like you know just a little
more than just the line you could join
the dark side is that that's just
standard now every every sit says that
every bad guy says that join the dark
side
I want like five more in action you know
I needed anything that was no
explanation of what is going on in this
world outside of the main characters who
like totally understood no but most is
awakened refreshing if I'm complaining
that I don't know what's going on in the
universe because it's not a political
talk but I totally know what the
characters I have completely refreshing
in a Star Wars movie now I never thought
I'd say that because I love the original
trilogy but so but that is my one
complaint I'm like I almost think like
so much of this plate is the sort of
apology to the prequels it was like what
we're gonna build them in the soulja
we're gonna throw in all these engines
honestly one of the few things that took
me out of it were all the little in
jokes that turning on the chest said
yeah it's got half that's right away the
little training ball and stuff it's like
okay is it was fast it was harmless it's
like okay yeah there were a little kiss
key go yeah because some of the like few
little things that actually took me out
of it more than anything but yeah I
don't know I thought overall the rest
was a solid film it just little bit of
construction problems going on in the
middle and I I just feel giving us a
sense of what's important like telling
us in the script why we should give a
crap this much cuz yeah like the
briefing like Laius sitting there like
and just like well I guess we're gonna
get attacked soon like if you think of a
new hope like you're sitting there
biting your nails the whole time you
know Death Star approaching doesn't that
never what they did it they're literally
like in the same scene
the same exact screen with the little
green lines they haven't updated at all
those years I mean oh I that's what took
me out of it I'm like I saw all of this
already all of this you know and I liked
when they had those characters I liked
when they're doing new stuff I liked
when they doing the connections and
stuff like that why are we doing a
retread of that you know even even the
rich are the Jedi they have to blow up
another Death Star but it's not gonna
blow up another planet it's not like hey
it's a ticking time bomb to this one
plan for blowing up a bunch of ships and
leads and then they had to get into the
shit like the and on top of it there's
other stuff going on I just don't want
another super weapon but they didn't
wreck it for me I will say this the idea
of if you are gonna do it which I
forgive you you don't need to I like
that it's a planet I thought that was
kind of clever ditching has its own
environment and trees and stuff wait I
don't like it I just I feel like somehow
maybe that should have been safe for the
third it like if you're gonna like they
maybe should have been some other weapon
that's not round shaped and yeah not
have been a cool I think that would have
been a really cool idea like in the
third movie like pure giant hidden
fortress and space kind of thing where
it's like wow now it's a whole planet
you have to invade the fucking planet
and so just this smaller like moon space
it like you know what got me both the
most scared in the most excited and
therefore unloved it uh Jedi Temple what
the hell is a Jedi Temple yeah I wasn't
the first Jedi Temple what is this
tell me more about this and something
will uh wave racist arrow was mark from
the room and he was asking if I would
eat how you think this new Star Wars is
gonna be like onto picture I'll be fine
you know it'll be okay whatever he says
I think they're mostly gonna play it
safe because it's the first one and
after that they'll go on to the more
risky stuff like this doesn't have hot
army that much you're like flipping the
fuck out and I'm like no no no it's like
all the other repeats I can do I say
something about that climax
I'm just like but you already did this
exact same flight next wine look and now
you're going like your desk our type
thing suck but I don't have a problem
with the rest of it like you're focusing
on this one thing that's a big part
that's supposed to be
then you're part of Baumann that's part
of my complaint it really wasn't that
was the side story really but isn't that
kind of a problem I mean it's like I'm
here wishing I could rotate out of a
problem for a different sense using it
as a way to be like I just destroyed the
whole last 20 minutes I'm like okay so
you're throwing the baby out with the
bathwater basically no it's not like I
said them when he says join the dark
side with me and stuff like that like I
said start to get that connection again
but it's aside from that I'm just
watching these two people claim glowy
sticks you know it is not even you know
shot like anything they're phenomenal
so I love liked a little bit more with
that so but no that's not the part that
knowing animals well knowing me the most
is that it pretty much okay know as soon
as they break into a house goodbye like
a hundred rebus hours fans with their
fake lightsabers I'm sure as soon as I
said it was good
they're like you know fantastic you you
know I meet that that's how it works
oh where we stick what was your chosen
I'm don't around weapons well they don't
want the taxation back back I just want
I just wanna know what why the fuck
bears of Republic and of resistance as
there was essence amount other funding
like that's what I wasn't others oh
you're just not getting into you know
then claim the lightsabers that's what's
all about hey I totally wasn't available
before talking about well no no you talk
about the taxation so sorry not talking
about the Texas said angry hate mail to
here um so no but but I'm like I I like
I thought it was good I you know what it
is
I think the Star Wars movie you're all
expecting to see it even I can't
expected to see you're gonna see and I
mean that in a good way uh there's not
going to be a ton of surprises but
there's just enough to make it
interesting it's not like there's no
surprises in this I mean because like I
said we have to do this big long spoiler
corner uh but everyone I mean there's a
lot of surprises how I quit fit if
someone so tell you all this movie has a
lot of surprises they're the surprises
you think are gonna happen if that makes
sense
somebody's going to be related I'll be
character
he's gonna die you know it's somebody's
gonna be following us dying wasn't the
surprise to me no not and then the honey
having the son like I was figuring like
we would advocate it I was having a son
I'm just like in him being the dark when
I'm like wow okay hands a daddy I did
that one come on like jumped out to me
I'm like huh yeah no that's a that's a
good surprise you know it like that
person has to be related somehow or
something I would have thought Luke - I
thought was interesting that it was Han
um but I like that I like that I didn't
see that coming well I mean they're all
the crazy there is that kylo Ren really
was Luke Skywalker and I'm like yeah I'm
like listen nothing against Mark Hamill
cuz he is the man but I mean he's
getting up there here and I could just
look at that guy to let you know that's
not Mark Hamill in there you fucking
shitting me
yeah um so no it's it's it's a good film
it feels like Star Wars again it's good
to have it kind of good anime I'm
looking for a sense of childlike wonder
again it did it really did kid again
yeah I didn't and here's the weird thing
I'm gonna say this once and I'll never
repeat it again that is something I did
feel in Phantom Menace was I felt like a
kid again as stupid as it was and his
dumb as some things were why there was a
fun factor to it really yeah really yeah
yeah another part to another fun
executed horribly slob believe the the
dialogue and everything was aimed at
five girls but the most people find it
for how it's boring - that's amazing
clones is the most boring for me oh that
is the most boring yeah like you can
live like that eczema gained tremendous
ajaan I can actually sit there watch it
laugh at it go like what the fuck is
this and you could not pay me money to
sit through clones again like it's that
one you can pay me money if you want
I mean you a lot of money dragons you
can pay me a lot to see clones again but
it would have to be like a Scrooge
McDuck sized bag of my position yeah
yeah but ya know it's going and the
funny thing is like yes it felt closer
to a Star Wars movie but that was a very
joyless movie like yeah that wasn't no
feel like a kid again that was actually
killing kids yeah so yeah this is the
first emerges like as dark as this movie
guy with killing ha and stuff I'm like
there were so many kind of just fun
things in the sense of humor there's
there's a limb exploring yeah if that's
something I just what a Phantom Menace
that people forget like I know the
movies bad I don't like the movie but
I'm like you seem a boo it's very pretty
you see the underwater Ganga moral dance
Reaper you see chorus can you see tatah
ween again but like I felt like there
was a sense of exploring seeing the
world meaning a whole bunch of new alien
characters interacting with these things
now true we didn't like most of those
alien characters you know in the pretty
good book I got that out of Phantom
Menace and I didn't get it in clones I
didn't get it in sit even though SIF is
objectively I think a better movie yeah
I got it again here yeah I got some fun
I think the exploring element I think
really is al I think that really is a
big part because even just it with her
exploring that uh the start of story
it's a philosophy it to me is a little
bit reminders oh yeah a minute um so
yeah I definitely a good film like I
said it if you look the trailer you
think you're gonna like it
you'll like it um how much you'll like
it that they'll kind of be up to you if
you if you really want to see I want to
see a Star Wars film I want to go in and
blow up another Death Star that you will
get all of it you will definitely get it
if you're looking for new stuff you'll
get that too um it's just kind of a you
know pick your poison which one you
think you want more of budding this is
the first movie I'm hoping now that
they've got the apology done prequels
and they're like now see we remembered
what you like we're doing it again here
you go we remember see and it's executed
well like there's the you don't have to
worry like now that they've gotten that
out of their system let's see some new
stuff well and here's Jedi Temple we'll
see that Jedi Temple
here's the thing my personal opinion you
kind of
almost have to because they wrote
everything else into this movie that I'm
like I don't know you apart from Luke
Trainor
I don't know what else you can repeat
that much like we just repeated most of
it already
yeah that is a very good point it's like
what else could you do when you sort of
have one I don't wonder I'm wondering if
that was their intention like we're
gonna reboot this dude ultimate Star
Wars show and we're doing the Star Wars
these things so then we can do like the
real me go scoring theory we're saying
that we're starting this whole thing all
over again the family drama continues
again and now branch out into something
different next to yeah I I definitely
really want to see what else they're
gonna do with this um like I said they
planted just enough seats that's like oh
look at this grow into what could this
Oh
let's I forgot to mention that's all
totally kind to say is nothing okay good
mom ray hopping in the seat next to
Chewbacca after on died yeah like a lie
they gotta prepping yeah but I just get
such a like they're just very cute
together and Finn and Rey are keep
together they all have chemistry they
really do and holy fuck chemistry's in a
Star Wars something I forgot to mention
on the basic review the last thing I'll
say is that they're starting off with a
liar revealed story don't worry it
doesn't go the route you think it's
gonna go cuz I'm like oh man he's still
holding that light shit are we really
gonna do this in the third act halfway
through he's like you know no no look
here's the true thing let's it out he's
like okay but we still better than
anyone I'm not even in it was a great
light from Han - just like trust me
women know and all of the ways they're
like listen I know you're for sure yeah
okay what do ya big deal yeah no that
was that was great um I don't know why
you would mention it here because if
they're going straight to the spoiler
corner they fuckin seen it already I
know I know that's why I would I was
doing that yet I don't like that they do
is take this out of light you just say
yeah just somebody cut it the special
edition I was leading myself in this is
you're gonna see Jamie is Jabba the Hutt
aren't you you dick please just take the
mask off you do that also
oh gosh so no okay so yeah that's about
it I'll definitely a lot of fun go check
it out see for yourself you don't have
if you're watching this so um hope you
liked it it was the movie you were
looking for